yes it's that time of year again folks
when society calls on us to play our
part in the annual purge but one night
only all crime will be legalized
airports across America were buzzing
today as hordes of international
travelers arrived in the country to take
part in the annual purge it filled
commit Freedom Serbian called
murder tourists as America's annual
night of legal crime takes on a global
dimension for the first time it
experienced the page but as the
countdown to this year's purge continues
a campaign that threatens to end the
event for good is gaining momentum
opposition Senator Charlie Rowan has
outraged traditionalists by calling for
an outright ban on all projective a it
is a night that is defining our country
the purge has to come to an end that's
the most divisive purge night in history
approaches many fear for the safety of
this controversial senator it's time to
do something about that senator all
right let's begin
this is a commencement of the annual
purge at the siren all crime including
murder will be legal for 12 hours the
only way that I can win is to risk
everything my job is to eliminate risks
and keep you alive we are going to use
this year's purge to do some spring
cleaning someone betrayed us it's coming
for you we are on our own they want you
dead senator there's a whole world of
crazy out there
it's me on one goal right now survival
what are you doing outside on purge
night senator
hey I said assassination attempt look
attacking us
I need to make sure you get through this
night
purging is the American went in all
these rooms we got eyes and ears on
everything all right let's begin this is
your emergency broadcast system